so top top of the morning and I feel
like we do this almost every morning but
top in the morning is grease again I'm
sorry so you're an apology yeah European
bankers and officials are kind of
playing down what a Greek default might
mean for the wider eurozone economy
they're doing that because it looks like
we're not getting any movement on a deal
whatsoever and we have that big june
fifth deadline looming over greece so
you have to be don't believe the greek
Finance Minister Yanis about a focus
that there will be a deal by June the
fifth uh you know what I read the op ed
I wasn't quite convinced but maybe he'll
surprise us all justice is often in
project syndicate that's it right what
do you think John how do you honestly
and this is gonna sound glib I don't
think it matters right matters to Greece
and it probably manage to some of the
periphery countries but this has been a
headline for a year plus now and I think
the markets are reacting with the way
they should react everyone knows about
it a default you know while damaging to
the grease economy and Greek reputation
other thing is a big deal for the
markets can we say at this point that
it's priced down I think it's very
priced in really when people when it's
in every newspaper around the world it's
priced it should be yeah should buy
chasey matters to you doesn't matter to
John let's try next the second one maybe
this will be more interesting this one
thrown in for variety the International
Monetary Fund is saying that the Chinese
currency is no longer undervalued and
that could be a big deal because as we
all know China has been trying to get
reserve currency status for a long time
John um I think this does matter in the
long run I'm not charge a short-term
market mover but over the long run I
think China is moving up from a
developing country to a developed
country getting reserve currency status
is part of that process so I think this
is a step in that direction I just want
to throw out one number so standard
chartered estimates that one trillion
dollars worth of assets could switch
into the Chinese currency over the next
five years if they get reserve status
now is reserve status conferred by being
part of the strategic drawing is it the
SDR strategic try correct yes correct it
is that does that confer reserve status
or does it is is there more than that I
think that's right um it should be noted
though that there's a bit of a dip
and some opinion to put it politely
between the u.s. and the IMF on this
issue so that us still very much thinks
that Chinese currency is undervalued the
IMF is the one making noises all right
what is your number three the weather is
perfect out the markets are Green across
the board what's going to keep people in
their seats and not picnicking in
Central Park today hopefully people will
find this interesting we have a bumper
day of us data so we had durable goods
capital or goods orders were a bit
better than expected next up we have
case-shiller house prices we have new
home sales and we have that
all-important consumer confidence John
what data point matters to you most I
think between the two this morning the
one that matters the most is
case-shiller we saw really strong
housing stats last week we see we've
seen very strong household formations I
think everyone's been missing sort of
this pickup in housing which was such a
strong contributor to growth back in the
06 07 time frame maybe too much of a
contributor we we see that leading to
better second half growth I mean the
multiplier effect of housing is really
amazing right you buy a house you need
furniture you need gardening you need
all the other things that go along with
it and that is a really really strong
effect on employment and prices as to
what to what degree though one last
question before we have to run to Julia
our higher home prices as a barrier at
household formation I don't think so I
mean I think there's been a lot of pent
up demand right savings rate has been
going up household finances are in the
best shape we've seen in years and I
think people have finally that rising
household prices while it might slow
down a significant increase in house
price appreciation is good for household
finances and the rest of consumer
spending so I would look at as a
positive for the US economy